and this is the thing about you for all
I'm gonna start calling you the black
dick Clark I keep waiting for you to age
what does turning 46 what does that mean
to you I'm so sorry
have you seen 64 yeah I looked in the
mirror today I'm all speckled up but it
takes a village you got out of bed like
Beyonce I woke up like this I woke up
like this
flawless I'll tell you this but I am
fascinated by I want to know your beauty
routine I want to know what it is it's
Helen helping you because she looks good
too yeah what is it but you never seem
to age um I think it's just genes and
genes and nutrition all right yeah I
really do I just think it's genes and
also like you just got to work at it you
know I think for us as men like people
don't think we pay attention to our skin
like we have to you know like you like
that you have to exfoliate like a crazy
man you know you know any other thing
too like I know like what it'll eggs
crow's feet because and and smile lines
yes awesome
yeah just take care of your skin yeah
you know just take care your skin that's
a good thing